in in Dante's Inferno I think I
mentioned this at one point so Dante's
Inferno it's a very interesting story
it's a descent into hell and it's
actually one of the places that we sort
of derive the popular conception of Hell
was partly based on Dante's and empties
imagination on his work and what Dante
was trying to do was to discover the
hierarchical structure of evil and you
know you might think there's a
hierarchical structure of good some
things are better than other things but
there's also a hierarchical structure of
evil some evils are greater than other
evils and he put betrayal in the in the
in the lowest part of Hell right so if
you were betraying people you were right
besides Satan himself and so and I think
that's good that's very smart well Dante
was a genius after all and I think the
reason for that is that you see if
someone trusts you they're laying their
vulnerability open to you now they might
just be naive let's say and that's we
won't think about that because you're
just a child if you're naive you can
still be betrayed but if you're an adult
and you trust it's often because you if
you're an actual adult its you willingly
open yourself up knowing that you could
be hurt right because you're not naive
anymore so you decide to trust and you
say I'll open myself up and I know that
I'm laying myself open to you if you
choose to use that power and then that's
a good thing to know you know if you've
been hurt as a child or hurt as a naive
person you might say well why should I
ever trust again which is a really good
question and the answer is the reason
you trust again once you're an adult is
because you're courageous your
courageous it's an act of courage to
trust and the reason it's useful is
because if you trust someone you open
the door to reciprocity and negotiation
and cooperation and you entice the best
part of the person forward and so it's a
it's a courageous act but then if you
betray someone then what you've done is
you've taken the best part of them which
is the part that will courageously trust
you know with open eyes right and you've
stuck a dagger in that and so you've
purposefully damaged the best part of
them and so that's why it's such a
egregious fault and and it's often
people don't recover from that sort of
thing you
if you betray someone badly enough you
can you can damage them like you can
give them post-traumatic stress disorder
if you really if you really put your
mind to it and you know that's not just
a psychological disorder if you have
post-traumatic stress disorder it
produces permanent neurological
alterations that make you more neurotic
more sensitive to negative emotion
really for the rest of your life like
you can you can recover from it to some
degree but stress will tend to reinstate
the PTSD so you you hurt someone and
it's not merely cycled not not that
psychological is merely but it's not
merely psychological right it's it's
fundamental physiological damage